Atherosclerosis is a
potentially fatal disease that can begin to
develop during childhood. This
disease is a process in which
fatty deposits called plaques
build up on the inner walls of
arteries, reducing or
completely blocking blood flow.
atherosclerosis
is not clear, many scientists believe
that it begins with damage to the
inner wall of the arteries called the endothelium,
substances carried by the blood
such as cholesterol, fat and
cellular waste accumulate in the damaged area
of ​​the arterial wall, the chemical reactions
that occur within the accumulation of
material cause  the
cholesterol molecules become oxidized, this results in an
inflammatory response in which
endothelial cells at damaged sites
release chemicals that signal
a call for help in response,
monocytes in the bloodstream are
directed to the damaged site, the
oxidized cholesterol stimulus converts
the  monoxides in macrophages macrophages
eat and digest
cholesterol molecules as a result of this process
macrophages transform into
foam cells that accumulate to form plaque
as the plaque increases in
size the arterial wall becomes
thicker and
hardens at the same time the
muscle cells  smooth cells in the arterial wall
begin to multiply
most of the smooth muscle cells
move toward the surface of the plaque
these cells contribute to the formation
of a firm fibrous cap that covers the
plaque finally the passage through the
artery narrows enough to
reduce the  blood flow and the amount
of oxygen received by the organs it
supplies over time the cap can corrode
and break open releasing the plaque into the
bloodstream the plaque can flow and
contribute to the formation of a clot
which can stop the flow of blood
as a result a  Limited
blood supply is available to the areas
surrounding the partially blocked artery,
degrading and potentially killing
neighboring tissues